During the last NBA season, I was sitting in my living room watching a random game on a random night with my son and wife. We do this all the time. She's sitting there grading papers. My son is doing his homework. And at some point during the game, my wife looks up at the TV and asks, why are so many of the players wearing that sleeve on their arm? I told her that those are compression sleeves. They're like a medical thing.
在上一赛季的NBA比赛中，我正坐在客厅里，和妻子与儿子在一个普通的夜晚随性地看着一场比赛。我们经常这样。她坐在那里改作业，我儿子在写作业。比赛进行到某个时候，我妻子抬起头看着电视问：为什么那么多球员的手臂上都戴着那个袖套？我告诉她那是压缩袖套，类似于医疗用品。
But then she's like, so all of them have medical issues, like elbow issues? And that's a simple question, kind of stopped me in my tracks. I started counting, and eight out of the ten players in the court had them on. At this point, I'm like neurotically counting. Whoever subs in, whoever's sitting on the bench, how many of these players are wearing the sleeve? And everyone's got one on. Look, what's going on with this? There is no way they all have elbow issues.
但接着她说：所以他们都有医疗问题，比如手肘问题？这是一个很简单的问题，却把我问得有点懵。我开始数起来，场上十个球员里有八个都戴着。此时我开始神经质地数着。无论谁替补上场，无论谁坐在替补席上，到底有多少球员在戴这个袖套？结果每个人都戴着。听着，这到底是怎么回事？他们不可能都有手肘问题。
This is Ramteen Arablewe. He's a producer and reporter. You might know him from the NPR show, ThruLine. Is it a blood flow thing? Is it something about their shooting range? Turns out the sleeve isn't there to do anything, really. It's just a look. The sleeve is fashion.
这是拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布卢伊（Ramteen Arablouei）。他是一名制作人和记者。你可能在NPR的节目《ThruLine》中听过他的声音。这是关于血液循环的问题吗？是关于他们的投射范围吗？结果证明，这个袖套其实并没有什么实际作用。它只是一种外观，袖套就是时尚。
And this fashion is also pretty new. If you go back and watch an NBA game from the 1990s, the era I grew up watching them, you won't see anyone with these sleeves on. Not one player. It seems like it came out of nowhere and now it's everywhere. So I looked into it. And what I found was that the story of the sleeves, is really the story of Alan Iverson,
而且这种时尚还相当新颖。如果你回看20世纪90年代的NBA比赛——也就是我伴随着成长观看的那个时代——你不会看到任何人戴着这些袖套。一个球员都没有。它似乎凭空出现，而现在却无处不在。所以我对此进行了研究。我发现，袖套的故事，其实就是阿伦·艾弗森（Allen Iverson）的故事，
an underdog player who went from a prison cell to international fame in just a few years. Iverson had a huge impact on the sport. In sort of the same way Michael Jordan changed how the game has played, Iverson changed the culture around basketball. And through the story of him and his sleeve, you can see the whole history of basketball's relationship with race, with respectability politics,
他是一个从监狱牢房在短短几年内走向国际名气的励志球员。艾弗森对这项运动产生了巨大的影响。就像迈克尔·乔丹改变了比赛的打法一样，艾弗森改变了篮球周围的文化。通过他和他袖套的故事，你可以看到篮球与种族、体面政治之间关系的整个历史，
and who gets to look like? what on the court. From 99% Invisible and BBC studios, this is a history of the United States and 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the basketball sleeve from reporter
以及在球场上谁有资格长成什么样。来自99% Invisible和BBC工作室，这是关于美国历史与100件物品的节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。今天，由记者拉姆蒂恩·阿拉布卢伊带来的篮球袖套的故事。
Ramteen Arablui. This past season was a huge one for the NBA, and I'm not just saying that because I'm a Knicks fan. When I was sitting there watching all these players rocking their compression sleeves, so was everyone else. NBA viewership was at the highest
刚刚过去的这个赛季对NBA来说意义重大，我这么说绝不仅仅因为我是尼克斯队的球迷。当我坐在那里看着所有这些球员穿着他们的压缩袖套时，其他人也一样。NBA的收视率达到了几十年来的最高水平
it's been in decades. Nationally televised games had celebrities sitting courtside. The whole thing looked glamorous and big and more expensive than ever. But it wasn't always like this. The 1970s were the era of tiny shorts,
。全国电视转播的比赛吸引了各界名流坐在场边。整个场面看起来光鲜亮丽、宏大而且比以往任何时候都更加昂贵。但情况并非一直如此。20世纪70年代是短裤、
the high socks and afros. The fashion was iconic. But not that many people were watching. Viewership numbers were really low. A lot of games weren't even shown live. were taped and then aired later, sometimes after 11.30 p.m. Fist fights broke out on the court regularly, something you rarely see today. The game was just extremely physical. And there was this
高筒袜和爆炸头的时代。那时的时尚极具标志性。但当时看比赛的人并没有那么多。收视率数字真的很低。许多比赛甚至不会进行现场直播，而是录像后播出，有时在晚上11点30分之后。球场上经常爆发拳击斗殴，这在今天是很难看到的。比赛极其充满身体对抗。而且当时有这样一种
feeling, this impression many people had about the league, that the real problem with the NBA was that it was too black, and not just meaning black in demographics, but that they didn't play the right way. This is Teresa Rundsteadler. She's a former NBA champion. Cheerleader turned historian, and she wrote a book about this era of the NBA called Blackball. They were playing streetball, that they were using drugs, that they were uncontrollable off the court, that they were lazy, that they weren't team players. The NBA had been segregated until 1951, and the 1970s marked the first time the league was majority black. The media often blamed the black players for the problems with the game,
感觉，许多人对联盟的印象是，NBA真正的问题在于它太黑了，不仅是指人口统计意义上的黑，而是指他们的打球方式不对。这是特蕾莎·伦斯泰德勒（Teresa Runstedtler）。她是一位前NBA冠军啦啦队员转型的历史学家，她写了一本关于NBA这一时期的书，名为《黑球》（Blackball）。他们说他们打的是街头篮球，说他们吸毒，说他们在场外无法无天，说他们懒惰，说他们不是团队球员。NBA直到1951年才取消种族隔离，而20世纪70年代标志着该联盟历史上首次黑人球员占多数。媒体经常将比赛的问题归咎于黑人球员，
sometimes accusing them of rampant drug use. I did a quick search in one of the newspaper databases, typed in cocaine and NBA, and was shocked at the number of articles that immediately came up in the search. Now, there was a lot of drug use, especially cocaine, in a bunch of professional sports in the 1970s, no doubt. But many of these stories published about NBA players were based on room.
有时指责他们猖獗吸毒。我在一个报纸数据库里做了快速搜索，输入了“古柯碱”和“NBA”，结果立刻弹出的文章数量让我大吃一惊。当然，在20世纪70年代的许多职业体育中，确实存在大量的毒品使用，尤其是古柯碱，这毫无疑问。但许多关于NBA球员的报道都是基于谣言。
and innuendo. There was even an LA Times article that cited several anonymous sources in the NBA. Saying that 40 to 75% of basketball players in the NBA were using cocaine. But years later, many of those sources came out and said, Listen, we were misquoted in that article. We didn't even say that. But that narrative was already everywhere. The NBA was seen as dangerous and unhomless. wholesome. And then in 1977, something else happened, this time on the court, that would make things much worse. It was a regular season game between the L.A. Lakers and Houston Rockets. It was in
和捕风捉影。甚至有一篇《洛杉矶时报》的文章引用了NBA内部几个匿名消息源，称NBA中40%到75%的篮球球员都在使用古柯碱。但多年后，其中许多消息源站出来说：“听着，我们在那篇文章中被断章取义了。我们根本没说过那些话。”但这种叙事已经无处不在。NBA被视为危险且不健康的。然后在1977年，又发生了一件事，这次是在球场上，这使得情况变得更加糟糕。那是洛杉矶湖人队和休斯顿火箭队之间的一场常规赛。比赛进行到
the third quarter. A scuffle broke out between two players underneath the basket, and it continued on as other players tried to break it up. A Lakers player named Kermit Washington, who was involved in the initial altercation, was standing at half court when He saw somebody coming out of the corner of his eye. It was Rudy Tomjanovich. Kermit saw Rudy Tomjanovich, a Rockets player, and thought he was coming after him. And he just punched and injured Rudy Tomjanovich very badly. One punch.
第三节。篮筐下方两名球员之间爆发了一场冲突，随着其他球员试图劝架，冲突仍在继续。一名名叫克米特·华盛顿（Kermit Washington）的湖人球员卷入了最初的冲突，当时他正站在半场附近，突然他眼角的余光看到有人冲了过来。那人是鲁迪·汤姆贾诺维奇（Rudy Tomjanovich）。克米特看到了火箭队球员鲁迪·汤姆贾诺维奇，以为他是来找自己算账的。于是他直接一拳打过去，把鲁迪·汤姆贾诺维奇打得非常严重。就一拳。
Washington hit Tomjanovich directly in the face. He fell to the ground, writhing in pain. He was hospitalized and underwent several surgeries. He was left with the gunned. permanent injuries and chronic pain. Kermit Washington's life would also change because the story became national news. Out of this came a huge outcry
华盛顿直接击中了汤姆贾诺维奇的面部。他倒在地上，痛苦地扭动着。他被送往医院并接受了多次手术。他留下了永久性的伤害和慢性疼痛。克米特·华盛顿的生活也将因此改变，因为这个事件成为了全国新闻。由此引发了巨大的抗议浪潮
calling for his punishment. He became persona non grata. His whole life kind of went into a spiral after that point. Tomjanovich is white and Washington is black. So this tragic incident just further cemented the idea being portrayed in the media that basketball was becoming this space
，要求对他进行惩罚。他成了不受欢迎的人。自那以后，他的整个人生可以说陷入了螺旋式坠落。汤姆贾诺维奇是白人，而华盛顿是黑人。因此，这起悲惨的事件进一步巩固了媒体所描绘的看法，即篮球正在变成这样一个空间：
where you had essentially big black men who were criminals who were beating up white men on the court and then that became the kind of narrative that mainstream Americans
在这里，你基本上有一群黑人壮汉，他们是罪犯，在球场上殴打白人男子，随后这就成为了当时的美国主流人群
had for the NBA at that time. A narrative that fit perfectly into the larger issues happening in the U.S. in the late 1970s. There was terror in a lot of neighborhoods last night. Police have described the looters as animals. As the United States really entered into the worst of what they call the urban crisis.
对NBA的固有看法。这种叙事完美契合了20世纪70年代末美国发生的更大社会问题。昨晚许多社区都陷入了恐慌。警方将这些暴徒描述为动物。随着美国真正进入了他们所称的城市危机的最糟糕阶段。
Like a swarm of locust is the way one Harlem cop described the looters. Disinvestment from black neighborhoods. The South Bronx, 500 acres littered with devastated buildings and rubble. Increasing crime and white flight. to the suburbs. The Jews, the Irish, and the Italians began to move out. The South Bronx became a ghetto of the very poor who were mainly black and Puerto Rican. The NBA became a kind of microcosm of that larger social problem.
一位哈林区警察曾用“蝗虫过境”来形容那些掠夺者。黑人社区的资金撤离。南布朗克斯，五百英亩的土地上满是被毁的建筑和瓦砾。不断上升的犯罪率和白人向郊区的逃离。犹太人、爱因斯坦（注：原意为爱尔兰人）和意大利人开始搬走。南布朗克斯变成了极度贫困人口的贫民窟，主要是黑人和波多黎各人。NBA成为了更广泛社会问题的一个缩影。
The NBA was in the dumps. But the league's fortunes would quickly shift in 1980. Two generational players, one white and one black, entered the league and took it by storm. They're given a magic. He's got Cooper on his right. Magic Johnson and Larry Bird. Outstanding afternoon. He looks like he could be headed for one of his big. They both stood 6'9, they were both incredibly skilled and fun to watch, and they were arched rivals.
当时NBA陷入了低谷。但联盟的命运在1980年迅速发生了转变。两位划时代的球员，一白一黑，进入联盟并掀起了风暴。他们被赋予了一种魔力。他右侧有库珀。魔术师约翰逊和大卫·伯德（注：应为拉里·伯德）。出色的下午。他看起来正朝着他的一项重大成就迈进。他们俩身高都是6尺9寸，都具备不可思议的球技，观赏性极强，而且他们是死敌。
For the NBA, it was like a miracle from the basketball gods. So you have these two men of different races who are on different coasts, who are battling. out. Let's start with Magic Johnson. He played for the Los Angeles Lakers. Who is this very effervescent personality. He has a huge smile and he's very charming. He's showtime. He represents Hollywood. But he's also got the vibe of a friendly neighbor. He's just very abluent, you know, fun to watch. Then there's Larry Bird. He's from rural Indiana, but plays for the Boston Celtics. who kind of epitomizes the Midwest, the kind of white Hoosier history of basketball.
对于NBA来说，这就像是篮球之神降下的神迹。所以你有这两个不同种族的男人，在不同的海岸，进行着激烈的对抗。让我们从魔术师约翰逊开始。他效力于洛杉矶湖人队。他有着非常热情洋溢的个性。他总是带着巨大的微笑，非常有魅力。他是表演时刻（Showtime）。他代表了好莱坞。但他也有一种友好邻居的气质。他就是那么意气风发，你知道的，很有看头。然后是拉里·伯德。他来自印第安纳州的农村，但效力于波士顿凯尔特人队。他有点代表了中西部，那种白人胡齐尔人（Hoosier）的篮球历史。
He was lovingly called the Hick from French Lick. He rarely smiled. He talked a lot of trash on the court. And he came across as working class and serious, almost the complete opposite of Magic Johnson. And so it became Magic versus Bird, Black versus White, West Coast versus East Coast. the rivalry was the perfect sports storyline in the racially and class stratified United States and the NBA's new commissioner. David Stern.
他被人亲切地称为“弗伦奇利克的乡下小子”。他很少笑。他在球场上喷很多垃圾话。他给人的感觉是工人阶级出身且严肃认真，几乎与魔术师约翰逊完全相反。于是这就变成了魔术师对决伯德，黑人对决白人，西海岸对决东海岸。这场宿敌对决成为了在种族和阶级分化的美国以及NBA新任总裁大卫·斯特恩眼中完美的体育故事线。
He saw this narrative as a path to reach his radical vision for the NBA. He begins to think about the NBA as a kind of multinational corporation. A corporation that needed a makeover, a new image to move away from the struggles of the 1970s. He looked at the NBA as being more akin to Disney than the NFL. So the NBA made their focus games that featured magic versus bird. I think that one of the things that our sport does is it gives you our players unadorned. This is David Stern from an interview explaining his approach from marketing the NBA. They're not wearing a lot.
他将这个叙事视为实现其对NBA激进愿景的途径。他开始将NBA视为一种跨国公司。一个需要改头换面、重塑形象以摆脱20世纪70年代困境的公司。他认为NBA更类似于迪士尼而不是NFL（美国国家橄榄球联盟）。因此，NBA将重点放在以魔术师对决伯德为特色的比赛上。我认为我们的运动所做的事情之一，就是向你展现未经修饰的球员。这是大卫·斯特恩在一次采访中解释他营销NBA的方法。他们穿得不多。
They've got no helmets, no long-sleeve uniforms. And you can see the expressions on their faces. And that expression, I think, capsulizes their personality. He didn't want to just focus on the game itself. He wanted the players and their personalities to take center stage. This seems obvious now. But it was kind of revolutionary at the time. And our fans understand that we've got 300 great players,
他们没有戴头盔，没有长袖队服。你能看到他们脸上的表情。我认为，这种表情概括了他们的个性。他不仅想关注比赛本身，还想让球员和他们的个性成为舞台的中心。这在现在看来似乎显而易见。但在当时可以说是具有革命性的。我们的球迷理解我们有300名伟大的球员，
but we've got 300 different personalities. David Stern's focus on individual personalities worked. By the early 1990s, the NBA had made huge strides in terms of audience and profits. Games were being televised live with huge viewership. Team owners and players were making millions of dollars. then David Sternion that he is me got to see that's how I dream to be
但我们有300种不同的个性。大卫·斯特恩对个人个性的关注奏效了。到20世纪90年代初，NBA在观众人数和利润方面取得了巨大的进步。比赛通过电视进行现场直播，收视率极高。球队老板和球员赚取了数百万美元。然后大卫·斯特恩……（注：此处原文音频有杂音或重复，略作平顺翻译）
then David Stern and the NBA got lucky again with the ascension of arguably the greatest player to ever live Michael Jordan won six championships in the 1990s he became an absolute legend and he did that partly by carefully crafting a public image that was inspiring
然后大卫·斯特恩和NBA再次幸运地迎来了可以说是史上最伟大球员的崛起。迈克尔·乔丹在90年代赢得了六次总冠军，他成为了一代传奇，而他部分是通过精心打造一个鼓舞人心的公众形象来做到这一点的
and motivational He was seen simultaneously as mysterious and accessible, edgy yet inviting. But maybe most importantly of all, completely devoid of any political content. Michael Jordan is kind of like this blank slate upon which anyone can project whatever their values are. Jordan was a perfect canvas for advertisers. He could mold his image into whatever was needed for his,
兼具神秘感与亲和力，既前卫又迷人。但也许最重要的是，他完全没有任何政治色彩。迈克尔·乔丹就像是一张白纸，任何人都可以把自己的价值观投射到他身上。乔丹是广告商完美的画布。他可以把自己的形象塑造为符合自己所需的东西，
own brand. It was reported that once Jordan told his teammates that he wouldn't endorse a Democratic Party politician in a Senate race because... Republicans buy sneakers too. He was also meticulous about how he looked. Jordan showed up to games and did postgame interviews in perfectly tailored designer suits. He always looked like a professional, like a businessman. Michael Jordan is CEO Jordan. This is from a TV ad called Michael Jordan, CEO. He literally changes from his bull's uniform into a suit in the ad and becomes a CEO. Of course it was tongue in cheek, but it also reflects reality.
为了他自己的品牌。据报道，乔丹曾告诉他的队友，他不会在参议院竞选中支持民主党政客，因为……共和党人也买运动鞋。他对自己的外表也一丝不苟。乔丹出席比赛以及赛后采访时总是穿着剪裁完美的定制西装。他看起来总是像个专业人士，像个商人。迈克尔·Jordan是CEO乔丹。这段出自一个名为《迈克尔·乔丹，CEO》的电视广告。他在广告中 literalmente 从公牛队的队服换成西装，成为了CEO。当然这带有调侃意味，但也反映了现实。
Today, the Jordan brand is estimated to be worth hundreds of millions of dollars. He was the perfect fit for what David Stern was trying to do with the NBA, a clean-cut, carefully crafted superstar for a family-friendly corporate league. Whereas, you know, in the previous generation, you know, if we're thinking of style icons from the 70s, we're thinking of somebody like, you know, Walt Clyde Frazier. Walt Frazier was a star guard for the New York Knicks in the 1970s. He's a Hall of Famer and considered one of the greatest players of all time. He's also a style icon. Somebody who was very much of that black New York culture with the fedore. with the fur, with the excess. You know, he was sort of like this figure
今天，乔丹品牌的价值估计高达数亿美元。他非常契合大卫·斯特恩试图对NBA做的事情——为这个家庭友好型的商业联盟打造一个形象正面、精心策划的超级巨星。然而，你知道的，在前一代人中，如果我们想到70年代的风格偶像，我们会想到像沃尔·克莱德·弗雷泽这样的人。沃尔·弗雷泽是20世纪70年代纽约尼克斯队的明星后卫。他是名人堂成员，被认为是史上最伟大的球员之一。他也是一位风格偶像。一个非常具有那种带着费多帽、穿着皮草、充满奢华感的纽约黑人文化特色的人。你知道的，他某种程度上就像是那个时代
of black urban cool at that time. But by the time you get to Michael Jordan, it's kind of been neutered of all of that context. Michael Jordan was portrayed and marketed as the kind of black man that didn't offend, who was acceptable to everyone, who was helping to sell the NBA to the world and cultivate a reputation
黑人都市酷炫的象征。但到了迈克尔·乔丹这里，这一切背景都被阉割了。迈克尔·乔丹被塑造和营销为那种不得罪人的黑人男性，一个所有人都能接受的人，他帮助将NBA推向世界并树立了一种声誉，
that left the problems of the 19-7. 70s behind. And other players started to emulate Jordan. Suits and ties became the unofficial dress code for players who wanted to be taken seriously. But this perfect calibration of performance and respectability was about to get disrupted by a new, undersized player who entered the league in 1996. A player who was so good, many people thought he could become the heir apparent to Michael Jordan. A player they called... The answer. With the first pick in the 1996 NBA draft, the Philadelphia 76th is select Alan Iverson from Georgetown University.
将70年代的问题抛诸脑后。其他球员也开始效仿乔丹。西装革履成了那些希望被严肃对待的球员的非官方着装要求。但这种对表现和体面感的完美校准，即将被一位在1996年进入联盟的矮个子新秀所打破。一个如此优秀的球员，以至于许多人认为他可以成为迈克尔·乔丹名正言顺的接班人。一个被称为……“答案”的球员。在1996年NBA选秀大会上，费城76人队用状元签选中了来自乔治城大学的阿伦·艾弗森。
But unlike Michael Jordan, Alan Iverson wasn't going to wear a suit. Coming up, Alan Iverson remakes the NBA and leaves behind a sleeve. Iverson looks to answer with three. Allen Iverson with 39 just won. And the crowd rising to their feet. Alan Iverson arrived in the NBA with a huge splash. He dominated right away, becoming an instant star in the face of his team, the Philadelphia 76ers. He won the Rookie of the Year Award.
但与迈克尔·乔丹不同，阿伦·艾弗森可不会穿西装。接下来，阿伦·艾弗森重塑了NBA并留下了标志。艾弗森试图用三分球做出回应。阿伦·艾弗森得到39分刚刚赢下比赛。全场观众起立鼓掌。阿伦·艾弗森震撼登陆NBA。他迅速统治赛场，成为了他的球队——费城76人队的即时明星和门面。他赢得了年度最佳新秀奖。
He was aura personified. He just kept getting better each season. And I loved watching him play as a kid. He was an amazing score who could do anything on the court. Lynch picks it up. Here comes Iverson flying inside. How can someone so small fly so high? And he did it all at six feet tall, which was tiny in a league where most players were at least six inches taller.
他就是气场本身的化身。他的表现每个赛季都在变得更好。我小时候特别喜欢看他打球。他是一个神奇的得分手，在球场上无所不能。林奇抢到球。艾弗森飞身突入内线。怎么会有人如此矮小却能飞得这么高？而且他身高只有6尺（1米83），在一个大多数球员至少比他高6英寸的联盟里，这简直矮得像个小不点。
He was somebody who was incredibly quick on the court. He could do his crossover dribble and make people fall while they were guarding him. Now he's got stocked and he breaks. But Alan Iverson's road to NBA stardom wasn't straightforward at all. He was born in Hampton Roads, Virginia in 1975, a poor, fairly segregated part of the state. Despite his small frame, he was one of the best football and basketball players in this state in high school. He seemed to be on a clear path to being a professional athlete until... He was involved in this ruckus that was happening.
他在球场上速度极快。他能用出他的变向运球（crossover），让防守他的人摔倒。现在他拿球并突破。但阿伦·艾弗森通往NBA巨星的道路一点也不平坦。他1975年出生于弗吉尼亚州汉普顿罗兹，那是该州一个贫穷、种族隔离相当严重的地区。尽管身材矮小，他却是当地高中里最优秀的橄榄球和篮球运动员之一。他似乎有着一条通往职业运动员的光明大道，直到……他卷入了这场骚乱中。
I think it was at a bowling alley back in the early 90s. He was at a bowling alley where there was a huge fight in 1993. He was accused of hitting someone in the head with a chair and injuring them badly. He denied wrongdoing, but a Virginia court found him guilty of a felony charge and sentenced him to five years in prison. He was only 18 years old. He was this huge basketball star, but his future was very uncertain at that point. You know, when all that was taken away from me, I just tried to be as strong as I could.
我想那是在90年代初的一个保龄球馆。1993年，他在一家保龄球馆卷入了一场大规模斗殴。他被指控用椅子砸某人的头部并将其严重受伤。他否认自己有罪，但弗吉尼亚州的一家法院裁定他的重罪指控成立，并判处他五年监禁。当时他只有18岁。他曾是那个了不起的篮球明星，但当时他的未来变得非常不确定。你知道的，当这一切都被剥夺时，我只是试图让自己尽可能坚强。
This is Alan Iverson in 2001 recounting that dark period in his life. And it was tough for me when I got locked up because people would never let it go away. Like it was in a paper for a month or two straight. You know, it was on TV every day. After four months in prison, Virginia's governor granted Iverson clemency, saying he had doubts about the facts of his case. He got a second chance. He was given a scholarship to play basketball at Georgetown University.
这是2001年的阿伦·艾弗森，在回忆他人生中那段黑暗的时期。当我被关进去的时候，这对我来说很难，因为人们永远不会让它过去。就像连续一两个月上报纸一样。你知道的，天天上电视。在监狱里呆了四个月后，弗吉尼亚州州长给予艾弗森特赦，称他对案件的事实表示怀疑。他得到了第二次机会。他获得了在乔治城大学打篮球的奖学金。
He became a star there and eventually was the first pick in the NBA draft. Yet the shadow of his jail sentence followed him into the league. But he didn't shrink away from it. The core of who he was didn't change. And he wanted to represent the people that he knew that, you know, were closest to him. So he was just very unapologetic in that way. Trackmasters. Check him out.
他在那里成了一名明星，最终成为NBA选秀的状元秀。然而，他入狱的阴影一直跟随他进入了联盟。但他并没有退缩。他核心的自我并没有改变。他想代表他认识的那些人，你知道的，最接近他的人。所以他在那方面非常坦荡，毫不掩饰。Trackmasters。去听听他的歌。
It's the new A5s. You gotta rock him. Leave and put a zone in the league to try to stop him. He's the answer and the problem. You don't want it with the way that boy. By 2000, Alan Iverson was a full-fledged NBA superstar. He got the nickname The Answer. As in the answer to anything in basketball.
这是新款A5。你必须得穿。离开并在联盟里布下防区试图阻止他。他既是答案，也是问题。你可不想跟那个小伙子硬碰硬。到2000年，阿伦·艾弗森已经成为名副其实的NBA超级巨星。他得到了“答案”这个绰号。就像篮球场上任何问题的答案一样。
It was Alan Iverson. The 76ers had been struggling. Alan Iverson was the answer. The future of the NBA without Michael Jordan was uncertain, Alan Iverson was the answer. He had a shoe deal. He was in commercials. His jerseys were constantly selling out. And it wasn't just because of his play on the court. His appeal to fans was also about the way he carried himself, his brash, confident attitude, his authenticity, and the way he looked. While Michael Jordan wore suits, he came to the games wearing a dewrag.
那就是阿伦·艾弗森。76人队当时一直在挣扎。阿伦·艾弗森就是答案。没有迈克尔·乔丹的NBA未来充满了不确定性，阿伦·艾弗森就是答案。他签下了球鞋合同。他拍广告。他的球衣经常售罄。这不仅仅是因为他在球场上的表现。他吸引球迷的地方还在于他的行事风格、他傲慢自信的态度、他的真实以及他的外表。迈克尔·乔丹穿着西装，而他来比赛时戴着杜勒格头巾（durag）。
You know, he had the baggy jeans. He was wearing his Tims, wearing his cornrows. This was at a time where almost no players in the NBA were doing that. Most folks were like Michael Jordan. They shaved their heads or they kept, you know, they might have high tops or whatever. But it wasn't like a thing to wear your hair in such a quote-unquote black style. And then there were the tattoos. Iverson's arms were covered in them.
你知道的，他穿着肥大的牛仔裤。他穿着踢不烂（Timbs）靴子，梳着黑人编发（cornrows）。当时NBA几乎没有球员会这么做。大多数人就像迈克尔·乔丹一样。他们剃光头，或者保持着，你知道的，他们可能会留高平头之类的。但是像这样把头发梳成所谓的黑人风格可不是什么普遍的事情。还有纹身。艾弗森的手臂上满是纹身。
I mean, if you look back to the footage of Michael Jordan and others from the late 80s into the early 90s, maybe a few tattoos here and there, but not really on the level that Alan Iverson and his generation took it to. And this had an impact on the broader culture. Iverson helped to normalize tattoos for everyone. Because it used to be only a socialization. with people who went to prison or people who were in the military.
我的意思是，如果你回看80年代末到90年代初迈克尔·乔丹和其他人的录像，也许偶尔有几个纹身，但真的没有达到阿伦·艾弗森和他那一代人所达到的程度。这对更广泛的文化产生了影响。艾弗森帮助人们对纹身习以为常。因为过去这只是坐过牢的人或当过兵的人的一种社交特征。
Irison wasn't trying to hide his past or to conform. He was saying, I'm proud of who I am, of where I come from. And this connected him with fans of all ages. He always looked like he was intentionally saying to all of his young fans, hey, I'm representing you. He just had a way about him where he, you know, had confidence in himself. This is Lenny Currier.
艾弗森并没有试图掩饰他的过去或随波逐流。他在表达：我为我是谁、我来自哪里而感到自豪。这使他与各个年龄段的球迷紧密相连。他看起来总是像在向他所有的年轻粉丝刻意传达：嘿，我在代表你们。他身上就是有一种自带自信的气质。这是伦尼·库里埃。
He was the Philadelphia 76ers trainer when Alan Iverson played there. He saw him almost every day. And he got to understand how intentional Iverson was about his look. He was meticulous. The shirt was halfway untucked. The pants might be droopy on his hips. It didn't look like he was meticulous. But let me tell you, he was.
阿伦·艾弗森效力费城76人队时，他是该队的训练师。他几乎每天都能见到他。他开始理解艾弗森对自己的外表是多么精雕细琢。他一丝不苟。衬衫半塞半露。裤子可能会搭在臀部。看起来好像不是刻意打理的。但让我告诉你，他绝对是。
Lenny says a friend of his, who was a high school teacher at that time, told him just how much of an impact, was having on his students. It was amazing how the kids, how they were just so enamored with Alan and wanted to look like him. So they wore the same kind of hairstyle. They wore their boots.
伦尼说他的一个朋友，当时是一名高中老师，告诉他艾弗森对他的学生产生了多么大的影响。孩子们太着迷于阿伦了，想要穿得跟他一样，这真是令人惊叹。所以他们梳同样的发型，他们穿靴子。
They wore, you know, everything that Alan was wearing, the kids at school wanted to wear. And people followed him. And he knew that. When everybody started looking like I looked, that's when I realized that I was a true.
他们穿着，你知道的，阿伦穿的一切，学校里的孩子们都想穿。人们都在效仿他。他心里很清楚这一点。当所有人都开始打扮得跟我一样时，我才意识到我成为了一个真正的。
This is Alan Iverson reflecting on his impact in an interview with Slam magazine in 2013. When I start seeing guys wear the du rag and hats and the jerseys and getting the corn rolls and then everybody flooding themselves with tattoos, stuff like that. You know, I sat back, man, that's cool. You know what I mean? Like everybody is trying to look like themselves but look like you. On the court, Alan Iverson played like he had nothing to live. lose. It was completely fearless. I don't know that I've ever seen an athlete. It was
这是阿伦·艾弗森在2013年接受《Slam》杂志采访时对自身影响的反思。当我看到小伙子们戴着头巾、帽子、球衣，梳着脏辫，然后所有人都纹满纹身之类的时候。你知道的，我往后一靠，心想，这太酷了。你知道我的意思吗？就像每个人都试图不像别人，而是像你一样。在球场上，阿伦·艾弗森打起球来就像一无所有、无需顾忌。他完全无所畏惧。我不知道我是否见过一个运动员。比阿伦更无畏。但这种无畏是有代价的，这个代价通常由他的身体来支付。
more fearless than Alan. But that fearlessness came with a price, a price often paid by his body. The way he played, he invited the contact. He invited the danger that came with, you know, trying to go up against seven-footers. Needless to say, he spent a lot of time picking himself up off the floor. And I had to go out and pick him up a few times. myself. Lenny says Iverson always played through injuries, but during the 2000-2001 season, he started suffering with pain in his right elbow, his shooting arm. He had something called Bersitis. Well, bursitis, your joints have what are called bursa sacks, they're fluid-filled sacks that provide lubrication for the joint. Some of the joints, those bursa sacks are a little bit
他的打法，他迎着身体接触而上。他迎着那些试图去对抗七尺长人所带来的危险。不用说，他花了很多时间把自己从地板上拉起来。而我不得不走过去，把他扶起来好几次。
more prominent and easier to, you know, damage, if you will, especially the elbow. So every time Iverson fearlessly drove to the basket and got knocked down by some seven-footer, he constantly had, you know, his elbow compromise, hitting the floor hard. Repeatedly causing trauma to the tissue. And if you've ever had this injury, you know, it sucks. It looks weird. It's just such an unusual swelling, and it's so inflamed. It's like it hurts to The normal way to fix elbow bursitis is to just rest it. Don't use it. It takes weeks, but eventually the swelling will resolve. But Alan Averson didn't have weeks. He was in the middle of a high-stakes season, a pivot point. After years of individual accolades, he was getting
伦尼说，艾弗森总是带伤作战，但在2000-2001赛季，他的右肘（投篮手臂）开始疼痛。他得了所谓的滑囊炎。嗯，滑囊炎，你的关节有被称为滑囊的东西，它们是充满液体的囊，为关节提供润滑。有些关节的滑囊更明显一点，更容易，你知道的，受到损伤，尤其是手肘。所以，每当艾弗森无所畏惧地突破到篮下并被某个七尺长人撞倒时，你知道的，他的肘部总是会受到损害，重重地摔在地板上。重复对组织造成创伤。如果你曾经受过这种伤，你就知道，这太糟糕了。它看起来很诡异。这是一种很不寻常的肿胀，而且发炎得厉害。就像痛得……修复肘部滑囊炎的常规方法就是休息。不要使用它。这需要几个星期，但最终肿胀会消退。但阿伦·艾弗森没有几个星期。他正处于一个高风险赛季的中期，一个关键的转折点。在经历了多年的个人荣誉之后，他因从未将球队带入总决赛而受到批评。他与老派教练关系紧张。有传言称76人队正考虑将他交易。艾弗森不能坐视不管。他需要能让他带伤上场的东西。我想他只是在寻找解脱，而我在寻找解决方案。
criticism for never bringing his team to the finals. He had tension with his old-school coach. There were rumors the 76ers were considering trading him. Iverson couldn't sit. He needed something that would allow him to play with his injury. I think he was just looking for relief, and I was looking for a solution. Lenny needed an answer for the answer. And the entire season, and Iverson's reputation was resting on it.
伦尼需要为“答案”寻找答案。整个赛季以及艾弗森的名誉都悬于一线。
No pressure. So first, Lenny thinks, we could try elbow pads. He never really wanted to wear padding. Think like your old gym teacher who coached volleyball. Big bulky pads, very uncool. He didn't really want to.
没有压力。所以首先，伦尼想，我们可以尝试护肘。他其实从来不想戴护具。想象一下教排球的老体育老师那种又大又笨重的护垫，一点也不酷。他其实并不想。
to do that. And honestly, Lenny didn't have that many options. Padding was the standard move. Yeah, I guess it was a little bit of a challenge. So then he tries something he'd never really considered putting on an elbow, compression stockinette. Yes, those things pregnant women or old folks put on to prevent blood clots. He thought, theoretically, it should help to compress and protect the elbow while not messing with range of motion. It would allow Alan Iverson to still be Alan Iverson. introduced the idea of putting that compression stocking on it one night, and it kind of sold him on it. So Lenny cut a custom size of the stocky net that would fit onto Iverson's arm.
去那么做。老实说，伦尼并没有那么多选择。佩戴护具是常规做法。是的，我猜这确实是一个小挑战。于是他尝试了一种他从未真正考虑过的东西——戴上肘部加压弹力绷带。没错，就是那些孕妇或老年人用来防止血栓的东西。他认为，从理论上讲，它应该有助于压缩和保护手肘，同时又不影响活动范围。这可以让阿伦·艾弗森继续做阿伦·艾弗森。有一天晚上，他提出了把这种加压弹力套戴在上面的想法，这某种程度上说服了他。于是伦尼剪下了一个适合艾弗森手臂尺寸的定制弹力套。
It was all white, made of cotton, breathable. But it definitely looked homemade. He liked the feel of it. So on January 21, 2001, Alan Iverson played his first game wearing the jenky white compression stockinet on his arm. Here's Iverson. Against Mark Jackson. The double team comes. And he floats it in.
它是全白的，棉质的，透气的。但它看起来绝对是自制的。他喜欢这种感觉。因此，在2001年1月21日，阿伦·艾弗森手臂上戴着那个粗糙的白色加压弹力套，打了他加入球队以来的第一场比赛。这是艾弗森。对阵马克·杰克逊。包夹来了。他抛投命中。
Alan Iverson's first bucket. Iverson came out on fire. All the way is good. Alan Iverson. He's two for two. And Lenny is watching this from the sidelines, locked in on Iverson's elbow. I was just thinking, I hope this works.
阿伦·艾弗森的第一个进球。艾弗森火力全开。球进了，好球。阿伦·艾弗森。他两投全中。而伦尼在场边看着这一切，目光紧盯着艾弗森的手肘。我当时只是在想，希望这管用。
Iverson off the screen, got an open look. He's in his first three. Iverson hit his first few shots and then just kept making them. Three-pointer. Good. Now, once again, over the 40-point mark. He has 41 points. He liked the way it felt.
艾弗森摆脱掩护，获得了一个空位出手的机会。这是他的第一个三分球。艾弗森投中了前几个球，然后继续进球。三分球。好球。现在，再次突破40分大关。他已经得到41分了。他喜欢这种感觉。
It was snug and it didn't, you know, interrupt his shot. Knifeing to the basket once again with 47 points. A big save and then a benefit of big. It was just, you know, the right product for him at that time. The 76ers ended up losing that game in overtime. But Iverson had one of the best games of his career, scoring 51 points, all while wearing a stocky net on his. arm.
它很贴身，而且你知道的，没有干扰他的投篮。再次犀利切入篮下，砍下47分。一次精彩的救球，然后是一记……这对他来说就是，你知道的，当时最合适的产品。76人队最终在加时赛中输掉了这场比赛。但艾弗森打出了他职业生涯中最好的比赛之一，砍下51分，而他的手臂上一直戴着弹力套。
You know, then he just, you know, began to wear it all the time every night and, you know, he would usually pull it off after a game and throw it into the crowd, you know, for some adoring fan. Iverson averaged 31 points a game, leading the league in scoring after putting on the sleeve. He won NBA MVP that season and for the first time took the 76ers all the way to the NBA finals. Even after his elbow Bresidus got better, he kept the sleeve on. And it became part of his iconic look.
你知道的，然后他就，你知道的，开始一直戴着它，每天晚上都戴，而且你知道的，他通常在比赛结束后把它脱下来，扔进人群中，送给某个崇拜他的粉丝。戴上护臂后，艾弗森场均得到31分，领跑联盟得分榜。他在那个赛季赢得了NBA常规赛MVP，并职业生涯第一次将76人队带入了NBA总决赛。即使他的肘部滑囊炎好转后，他依然保留着这个护臂。它成了他标志性造型的一部分。
It just clicked. I think he was just the right person to adorn that sleeve. I don't think we ever imagined it would become a fashion statement, if you will, and a fashion item. But at the same time, a small upstart sports apparel company called Under Armour was trying to create a market for functional sports gear, basically clothing items to make every person feel like a serious athlete. And they did imagine the sleeve. as a fashion item. The folks from Under Armour contacted us and said that they, you know, had a new product line they wanted to know if Alan would try it.
一拍即合。我认为他正是佩戴那个护臂的不二人选。我想我们从没想过它会成为一种时尚宣言，如果你这么认为的话，甚至成为一件时尚单品。但与此同时，一家名为“安德玛”（Under Armour）的小型初创运动服饰公司正试图为功能性运动装备创造一个市场，基本上就是打造能让每个人都觉得自己是严肃运动员的服装。而他们的确把护臂想象成了一件时尚单品。安德玛的人联系了我们，说他们，你知道的，有一条新的产品线，想知道阿伦愿不愿意试穿一下。
Elbow compression sleeves. They sent me, you know, a number of different, you know, pieces. And I wanted to ask Alan, me would you like to try these? And they built them really nicely. They were thick. So the sense of compression was still there. They also just looked sleek and cool, not like something Lenny had put together in the training room. That's what won him over. From then on, Iverson wore the underarmor sleeve in various
肘部加压护臂。他们给我寄了，你知道的，许多不同的，你知道的，样品。我想问问阿伦，你愿意试试这些吗？他们做得很精致。它们很厚。所以加压的感觉依然存在。它们看起来也很时髦很酷，不像伦尼在训练室里拼凑出来的东西。正是这一点打动了他。从那时起，艾弗森开始佩戴与他的球衣颜色相匹配的各种颜色的安德玛护臂。
colors that matched his jersey. Then it became, you know, a commercial product sold in all the sporting goods stores and sold online, etc. Over the next few years, other NBA players started wearing the sleeve, even if they didn't have elbow bursitis. Basically, everyone was trying to emulate Iverson's entire look. He'd transcended sports and reached the mainstream. He'd already brought hip-hop culture from the streets to the NBA, now players were even wearing his medical gear. Iverson was at the pinnacle of his power, both on the court and off. But that moment came at the same time that criticism of him was starting to pile up. This is a song Iverson released. This is a song Iverson released.
然后它变成了，你知道的，在所有体育用品商店出售并在线上热销等的商业产品。在接下来的几年里，其他NBA球员也开始佩戴这种护臂，即使他们并没有患肘部滑囊炎。基本上，每个人都在试图模仿阿伦·艾弗森的整体造型。他已经超越了体育界，走向了主流。他已经把嘻哈文化从街头带入了NBA，现在球员们甚至连他的医疗装备都在模仿。艾弗森无论是场上还是场下都达到了权力的巅峰。但那个时刻伴随着对他的批评声也开始堆积如山。这是一首歌，是艾弗森发布的。这是一首歌，是艾弗森发布的。
as a rapper in 2000. He got a bunch of flack for it. You have someone who is a 76 who is a focal point in the black community in particular coming out saying these horrible, disgusting lyrics, and it can't be tolerated. There are racial slurs, attacks on women, and a threat to kill gay people.
作为说唱歌手在2000年。他因此受到了大批抨击。你有一个76人队的球员，特别是在黑人社区中处于核心地位的人，出来说这些可怕的、令人作呕的歌词，这是不能容忍的。其中包含种族歧视言论、对女性的攻击，以及杀死同性恋者的威胁。
The NBA powers that be, they would embrace a certain kind of hip-hop aesthetic, but they didn't want any of the criminal associations being, you know, in your face at a game. Alan Iverson was the embodiment of that version of hip-hop aesthetic. And this is a guy who already had a criminal history. And soon, Iverson's every move and word was suddenly a news story. Here's an example.
NBA当权者，他们会接受某种形式的嘻哈美学，但他们不希望任何与犯罪相关的联系，你知道的，大摇大摆地出现在比赛中。阿伦·艾弗森就是这种嘻哈美学版本的化身。而且这家伙本身就有犯罪前科。很快，艾弗森的一举一动和说过的每一句话突然都成了新闻。这里有个例子。
At an infamous press conference right before the 2002 season, he was asked about missing 76ers practices. As we sitting in here, I'm supposed to be the franchise player, and we're in here talking about practice. I mean, listen, we're talking about practice. This clip has basically become a meme, and I remember what a big deal it was at the time. It makes Iverson seem spoiled and entitled.
在2002赛季开始前的一场臭名昭著的新闻发布会上，当被问及缺席76人队训练的事时。既然我们坐在这里，我本该是球队的招牌球星，而我们却在这里讨论训练。我的意思是，听着，我们在讨论训练。这段视频基本上已经成了一个迷因（meme），我记得当时这件事闹得有多大。这让艾弗森看起来被宠坏了，且不可一世。
Why won't he just show up to practice? But if you have the context, it makes more sense. It's the season after he won the MVP, and he's the best player in the league. And now leading up to the next season, he's frustrated because he's being asked questions about practice, not about his performance.
为什么他就不肯来参加训练呢？但如果你了解背景，这就更有意义了。这是他赢得MVP之后的那个赛季，他是联盟中最出色的球员。现在临近新赛季，他感到沮丧，因为人们问他的是关于训练的问题，而不是关于他的表现。
I know I'm supposed to be there. I know I supposed to leave by example. I know that. I'm not shoving it aside, you know, like it don't mean anything. But we're talking about practice, man. What are we talking about? Even the reporters in the room
我知道我本该去那儿。我知道我应该以身作则。我知道的。我并没有把它抛在一边，你知道的，好像它毫无意义一样。但我们在谈论训练，老兄。我们在谈论什么？甚至连房间里的记者
seem aware of how ridiculous the question is. We're talking about practice, man. We're talking about practice. Iverson had gotten a reputation as a bad boy, a thug. The shadow of his high school conviction followed him because he refused to conform. And that pissed off a lot of people. David Stern and the NBA were getting frustrated with all the negative attention, Alan Iverson, their MVP was bringing to the league.
似乎也意识到这个问题有多荒谬。我们在谈论训练，老兄。我们在谈论训练。艾弗森的名声已经变成了坏小子、恶棍。他高中时的定罪阴影一直跟着他，因为他拒绝顺从。这惹恼了许多人。大卫·斯特恩和NBA对阿伦·艾弗森这位MVP给联盟带来的所有负面关注感到越来越沮丧。
He wasn't the professional corporate businessman type of player that they would. used to marketing. And they worried the league was developing a bad image. And right on cue in 2004, something happened at a game that seemed to confirm their fears. In 2004, in a game between the Detroit Pistons and Indiana Pacers, a fight broke out between players, and soon it spilled off the court and into the crowd. Players and fans were squaring up and throwing punches. It was bad. The ball was called the malice at the palace.
他不是他们习惯于营销的那种职业化、企业高管型的球员。他们担心联盟正在树立一种糟糕的形象。就在这时，2004年，比赛中发生了一件事，似乎印证了他们的恐惧。2004年，在底特律活塞队和印第安纳步行者队的一场比赛中，球员之间爆发了一场冲突，很快冲突蔓延到了球场之外，波及观众席。球员和球迷剑拔弩张，拳脚相加。情况很糟糕。这场球被称为“奥本山宫殿斗殴事件”。
It became national news. Alan Iverson wasn't involved. He wasn't even there. And yet it seemed to confirm the narrative that the hip-hop culture he introduced into the league, the clothes, tattoos, the attitude, was really. ruining the NBA. You know, it almost follows the same playbook as the 1970s. Black criminality.
它成了全国新闻。阿伦·艾弗森没有参与。他当时甚至都不在场。然而，这似乎证实了一种叙事，即他引入联盟的嘻哈文化——服饰、纹身、态度——真的在毁掉NBA。你知道的，这几乎遵循了20世纪70年代同样的剧本。黑人犯罪率。
You know, here they are wearing cornrows. They're wearing their due regs. They look like they're straight out of a gang. NBA commissioner David Stern saw this as much of an image problem as anything else. And before the 2005 season, he instituted an official NBA business casual dress code. The list of things that were no longer allowed. It's basically everything that Alan Iverson ever wore to a game. Players could no longer wear sneakers.
你知道的，他们梳着黑人编发。他们戴着头巾。他们看起来就像是从黑帮里直接走出来的一样。NBA总裁大卫·斯特恩认为这和任何事情一样，是个重大的形象问题。在2005赛季之前，他制定了官方的NBA商务休闲着装规范。不再允许穿戴的物品清单。基本上就是阿伦·艾弗森穿去比赛过的所有东西。球员不再被允许穿运动鞋。
Duregs. Sunglasses inside. Large chains. Baggy jeans. The Tims. Even T-shirts. It's all of the things that we... The average fan...
头巾。室内太阳镜。大项链。肥大的牛仔裤。踢不烂靴子。甚至T恤。这些都是我们……普通球迷……
Thought was like the coolest thing ever for a basketball player to embody. And David Stern was sort of saying, nope, we're done with that. It was tough on me because I understood that it was a shot at me. This is Alan Arverson from an interview with Slam Magazine's founder from a year ago. People just wanted to look like themselves. You know what I mean? They wanted to wear what they wanted to wear a poster, what they thought they should wear because of the errors before us.
当时大家觉得，能够体现出这种特质对篮球运动员来说简直酷毙了。但大卫·斯特恩的潜台词似乎是：不，我们不再接受这一套了。这对我打击很大，因为我明白这是冲着我来的。这是阿伦·艾弗森一年前在接受《Slam》杂志创始人采访时说的话。大家只是想做回自己，你知道我的意思吗？他们想穿自己想穿的衣服，展示他们觉得在前人之后本该穿的风格。
You know, it was always suit and tie. And then once guys saw that I was doing that, it wasn't that they were copying me. It was like, oh, oh. you can't do this, you know what I mean? And guys just started dressing the way they wanted to dress. You know what I mean? But it was more on the hip-hop side, like to where it was baggy clothes and chains and earrings and watches.
你知道的，以前总是西装革履。然后，当大家看到我在那样穿的时候，并不是说他们在模仿我，而是像在说：哦，原来还可以这样，你知道吗？于是大家开始按照自己喜欢的方式穿衣。你知道我的意思吗？但这更偏向嘻哈风格，比如穿宽松的衣服、戴链子、耳环和手表。
And I guess David Stern was like, no. The dress code was seen as a direct response to the impact Alan Iverson had on the league. But Alan Iverson didn't always follow it. Neither did some of his teammates. They racked up thousands of dollars of fines for violence. And none of this helped Alan Arverson's reputation. He continued to be seen as a troublemaker. And that perception, as well as mounting injuries, hurt his place in the league. Just five years after his MVP season, he was traded to the Denver Nuggets.
我想大卫·斯特恩当时的心态就是：不行。这一着装规定被视为对阿伦·艾弗森对联盟产生的影响的直接回应。但阿伦·艾弗森并非总是遵守规定，他的部分队友也是如此。他们因违规被处以数千美元的罚款。这些都没有改善阿伦·艾弗森的名声，他依然被视为一个麻烦制造者。这种看法以及不断增多的伤病，损害了他在联盟中的地位。就在他荣膺常规赛MVP仅仅五年后，他就被交易到了丹佛掘金队。
He bounced around to two other teams, and by 2010, he was out of the NBA. The NBA had banned the clothes he wore, but the one thing they couldn't ban was the sleeve. It was a medical item, not fashion, but it soon became fashion. It became a representation of the way Iverson changed the game and the culture in the NBA. And it's the part of his brand that is still around. Watch an NBA game on any given night, and you'll see that half the players on the court are wearing elbow compression sleeves, that most of them don't even need for medical reasons.
他辗转效力于另外两支球队，到2010年，他彻底告别了NBA。NBA禁了他穿的那些衣服，但唯独有一件东西是他们禁不掉的——那就是护臂。它原本是一件医疗用品，而非时尚单品，但很快它就成为了潮流。它成了艾弗森改变NBA比赛风格和文化的象征，也是他个人品牌中至今依然存在的元素。随便看一个晚上的NBA比赛，你就会发现场上一半的球员都戴着肘部压缩护臂，其中大多数人甚至根本不需要出于医疗原因佩戴它。
And the market for elbow compression sleeves is now estimated to be over 500, million dollars. Companies extracted the one thing about Alan Iverson that wasn't overtly dangerous to the status quo and made a lot of money off it. But ultimately, what the sleeve symbolizes, to me at least, is Iverson's rebellion and how his ferocious sense of independence resonates even with players today who were just babies when he retired. There's so many players who style themselves, both in terms of how they play on the court and also off the court in the kind of legacy of Alan Iverson. Fast forward to now, I feel good about it because you see everybody else expressing themselves
如今，肘部压缩护臂的市场规模估计已超过5亿美元。各大公司提取了阿伦·艾弗森身上那些对既定秩序没有公开威胁的特质，并从中赚取了巨额利润。但归根结底，至少在我看来，这个护臂象征着艾弗森的叛逆，以及他那股强烈的独立精神是如何与当今的球员产生共鸣的——那些球员在他退役时甚至还只是婴儿。有那么多的球员都在塑造自己的风格，无论是在球场上的打法还是场下的穿搭，都带有阿伦·艾弗森的传奇色彩。快进到现在，我感觉很好，因为你看到其他所有人都在以自己喜欢的方式表达自我，
the way they want to. They feel good when they come in to work. Iverson is right to be proud of the impact he had on his workplace. Before NBA games today, there's this tradition where people, Players are shown on TV walking into the stadium through a tunnel. Their fashion choices have turned this into a runway. Players sometimes show up wearing bright red overalls or an outrageously oversized pink sweater
以他们想要的方式。他们走进球场时感觉很好。艾弗森为自己对工作环境产生的影响感到自豪是合情合理的。如今在NBA比赛开始前，有一个传统，那就是球员们被电视镜头记录下他们穿过通道走进球场的过程。他们的时尚选择将这里变成了T台。球员们有时会穿着亮红色的工装裤或者一件夸张的超大号粉色毛衣出场，
that looks like it belongs on a runway in Milan or Paris. This tradition emerged as its own way of resisting the NBA dress code. Just like Alan Irisen, players fought back by being authentic, by being themselves. The dress code was you could wear jeans, just wear a pair of shoes and a shirt with a collar. But our players went over the top. This is David Stern from a 2019 interview
看起来像是属于米兰或巴黎的时装周T台。这一传统作为一种抵制NBA着装规定的独特方式应运而生。就像阿伦·艾弗森一样，球员们通过保持真实、做自己来进行了回击。当时的着装规定是你可以穿牛仔裤，只需配上一双鞋和一件带领子的衬衫。但我们的球员做得过火了。这是大卫·斯特恩在2019年的一次采访中对着装规定影响的反思。
reflecting on the impacts of the dress code. Did you find it offensive that some people thought it was racist? Well, no, because race is always an issue. And the NBA, has always been on the edge of discussions of race. David Stern passed away in 2020. Many of the players that wear a compression sleeve today probably don't even know its history
你是否觉得有些人认为这其中带有种族主义色彩是被冒犯了？嗯，没有，因为种族问题一直都存在，而且NBA一直处于有关种族讨论的风口浪尖。大卫·斯特恩于2020年去世。如今许多佩戴压缩护臂的球员可能根本不知道它的历史，
or its connection to Alan Iverson. But every time they pull that sleeve up over their arm, they are carrying on a legacy, a legacy that reminds us of the ongoing tensions between race, respectability politics, and capitalism. It shows that black American culture cannot be controlled or regulated, that no matter how many rules the NBA put into place, self-expression found a way. Romteen Arablewe is a producer, reporter, sound designer, and composer. He is a co-founder
或者它与阿伦·艾弗森的联系。但每当他们把护臂往上拉过手臂时，他们就是在延续一段传奇——一段提醒我们种族、体面政治与资本主义之间持续存在的紧张关系的传奇。它表明，美国黑人文化是无法被控制或规范的，无论NBA出台多少条规则，自我表达总能找到出路。龙蒂恩·阿拉布卢韦是一名制作人、记者、声音设计兼作曲家。他是荣获皮博迪奖的节目《Thruvine》的联合创始人。
of the Peabody Award-winning show, Thruvine. Today, he's still making audio stories and finishing an immersive exhibit on the history of human vision that premieres in Las Vegas in September. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Romteen Arablewee, who also composed music for this story. Our series producers are Priscilla Alabe, Brenna Daldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Iver Manly. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2, From BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell.
今天，他仍在制作音频故事，并正在完成一个关于人类视觉历史的沉浸式展览，该展览将于9月在拉斯维加斯首映。《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios联合制作的节目。本节目由我——罗曼·马尔斯主持并策划。本集由龙蒂恩·阿拉布卢韦制作，他也为本故事创作了音乐。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿拉贝、布伦娜·达尔多夫和埃利·莱特富特。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，伊弗·曼利负责混音。艾米·布雷肯负责事实核查。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制作人是凯茜·2；来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。
Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in Beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, Email us at 100 objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特。插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯绘制。99% Invisible是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。BBC Studios总部位于美丽的西伦敦白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物品希望我们考虑，请发电子邮件至100 objects at 99PI.org。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。